hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es mal wieder ein
herzhaftes gericht und zwar mache ich
ein leckeres pizza brot oder besser
gesagt einen pizza krank und zwar
besteht es aus einem ganz normalen
pizzateig da habe ich jetzt auch mein
basis pizzateig rezept genommen und
später wird es gefüllt und
zusammengerollt und dann eben zusammen
kranz geformt und ich finde es ist das
ideale rezept einfach so wenn man lust
auf pizza hut aber irgendwas anderes
möchte und ein tolles party gericht
finde ich und ich zeige euch jetzt mal
kurz die zutaten für den pizzateig also
ich habe hier 450 gramm mehl 250
milliliter wasser ein teelöffel salz 1
esslöffel zucker ein viertel würfel hefe
sind so etwa zehn gramm
ich brauche drei esslöffel olivenöl und
etwas pfeffer ganz einfach geb ich
zuerst die hefe in die schüssel
ihr könnt den teig natürlich auch mit
der hand verkneten es macht derzeit in
der küchenmaschine weil es mir die
arbeit wegnimmt und eben auch schneller
geht dann der zucker mit rein dann etwas
wasser ich bringe ich bin übrigens auch
mit dabei wirklich immer mit dabei
jetzt fahre ich das skript damit sich
die hefe auflösen kann
dann gebe ich noch das restliche wasser
mit rein und auch das mehl und jetzt
lass ich jetzt erstmal verkneten
und ich mache es jetzt bisschen mit
temperatur also so oft 30 grad war dann
geht der hefeteig gleich bisschen
schneller auf
es könnte jetzt auch zum fügen
und auch besser
mit
und zum schluss gebe es jetzt noch drei
esslöffel olivenöl mit dazu
und lasst den teig jetzt ungefähr 15
minuten lang geschnitten
der teig ist jetzt schön weich geknetet
und klebt auch nicht mehr
jetzt habe ich hier schon ein bisschen
mehr auf die arbeitsfläche gestreut und
gedreht den tag drauf in form ich jetzt
gerade so zu einer kugel
und gebt ihn mit dem mehl wieder zurück
in die schüssel man kann nämlich darin
schon ein bisschen aufgehen
ich betrat kurz ein bisschen sauber und
zeigt euch gleich die zutaten für die
füllung für die füllung nehme ich jetzt
hier eine rote paprika eine zucchini
ich brauche zwei esslöffel olivenöl eine
zwiebel und hier unten habe ich noch
knoblauch zweiter und klug macht sehen
ich habe jetzt 200 gramm sawtschuk ein
paar oliven etwas thymian salz und
pfeffer und 125 gramm mozzarella und 150
gramm gouda käse und ich nehme jetzt
zuerst die zwiebel und die knoblauchzehe
und die schneidig klein einfach hin so
kleine würfel
jetzt gebe ich die zwei esslöffel
olivenöl in die pfanne und die pfanne
haben jetzt auch schon angebracht und
gibt die zwiebel und knoblauch würfel
mit dazu man könnte hier schon mal
bissel andünsten
und ich kann ihnen der zwischenzeit
schon mal das gemüse zerkleinern also
paprika und zucchini und habe jetzt hier
für diesen aufsatz und zwar sind es dann
so grobe stifter aber es kann man
natürlich auch mit messer klein
schneiden
das mache ich jetzt mal eben kurz
die panne habe ich jetzt übrigens ein
bisschen runter geschaltet damit mir die
zwiebel nicht verbrennen
jetzt kommt das gemüse mit rein kann ich
sowieso hochschalten und es wird dann so
etwa fünf minuten mit gegangen
und das gemüse gar ich jetzt ein
bisschen vor damit später in dieser in
diesem pizza kann sich rot bleibt weil
das ist ja nicht auf der oberfläche
sondern innen drin
und deswegen soll es müssen vor begab
werden
an der stelle können das jetzt auch
schon mal salzen und pfeffern
ich gebe auch schon mal thymian mit rein
und hilfe
und wäre masse zu vor sich hin gackert
kann ich schon mal den käse zerkleinern
und auch die oliven entsteinen und beim
käse nämlich jetzt diesen reibe vorsatz
also käse eintreiben entweder mit einer
küchenrolle oder in der küchenmaschine
der hefeteig ich schön aufgegangen und
ich habe jetzt hier etwas mehl auf die
arbeitswelt gestreut und wetten jetzt
voll und es riecht hier schon richtig
lecker mediterrane murat demir hals zu
stehen gibt es seit jahren sein
das riecht aber herrlich probieren oder
was
die ganze familie wieder da ich bei
meiner mama früher auch gemacht macht
immer hefeteig probiert so und den teig
hole ich jetzt so ein bisschen eckig aus
ich denke er hat jetzt so ungefähr 30
mal 50 350 gebe ich dir gleich und nicht
nehme ich diesen job stücke und legt die
darauf stieg in der wurst und zwar haben
wir die diesmal wohl bereits in scheiben
geschnitten gekauft hat die mädchen zu
job geklaute macht es murat akkaya man
die geschichte erzählen mal deutschland
ist saab gekauft ja ich war am samstag
beim globus nachts um halb zehn ganz
spät
ich hab ein bisschen heiß von henndorf
produkt und dann war ich am regal und da
waren schon mehrere mehrere leute vor
dem psychokrieg
und ich habe einfach nicht auf die soap
schauen können und habe dann die leute
ganz nett gefragt schon durfte ich mal
vorbei konnte mir ins boot holen und die
war nicht sehr nett natürlich damit
vorbei auf die social geholt und am
nächsten tag master sogar um die leute
gepostete mourad massi gäste haben
interviews chip regal wir haben nicht
gesehen
also wie gesagt diese leute nicht vorbei
gelassen haben die kann anscheinend die
sally und liza und mich haben wir auch
mehr erkannt auf jeden fall wenn ihr
euch das nächste mal ob du egal sein
haus gibt es zur job
solch eine packung sonst genau so und
ich habe jetzt de sutter bringe hier
darauf verteilt - da kommt jetzt das
gemüse drüber paris doch lecker aus
bricht auch richtig lecker und schmeckt
richtig gut ich hab eben schon
abgeschminkt
jetzt noch die oliven darüber verteilen
ich denke was da auch ganz gut reinpasst
10 pepperoni in fünf grad sagen dies
jetzt auto war wir hatten gerade ein
oder was auch toll wäre mit sicherheit
ist wissenschafts krise ja also ich hab
net rein weil du das eigentlich nicht
mehr wahr ich habe ja deswegen nehme ich
jetzt mozzarella und gouda aber
schafskäse wird dem ganzen natürlich
noch so ein bisschen den intensiveren
geschmack geben wobei hier mehr fällt
wohl ziehen
ja ich mag es richtig auf türkisch
spanisch
es gibt nicht viel besser aber das kind
sei und jetzt muss das ganze nur noch
aufgerollt werden
oder getrocknete tomaten wir auch wieder
her
ich wollte jetzt nicht zuviel rollt der
zug voll machen
ich denke wenn man zum beispiel auf
zucker verzichten möchte und das
vegetarisch zum beispiel hält würde ich
auf jeden fall getrocknete tomaten mit
rein geben weil die eben auch witzig
schmecken oder ansonsten wäre es nämlich
denke ich zufahrt somit der naht nach
unten habe ich jetzt hier auf der
arbeitsfläche legen eine riesenrolle und
selbst das jetzt auf mein backblech
jetzt fahren die das schön zu einem
kranz und hier verbinde ich jetzt die
enden noch miteinander
englisch ist auch so ein bisschen dieser
pizza calzone ihnen die füllung nur edel
nicht zusammengeklappt sondern
zusammengerollt
das war ein auch was ganz einfach es
werden ja total
und jetzt bestreichen die pizza rolle
den pizza kranz noch mit bisschen
olivenöl verleiht dem ganzen schönen
glanz und den ofen habe ich übrigens
mittlerweile auch schon vorgeheizt auf
200 grad celsius ober unterhitze
ich habe mich jetzt übrigens dazu
entschlossen den pizza kranz lieber auf
den pizza bat gleich zu backen deswegen
habe ich das jetzt kurz eingefettet und
ihr könnt es natürlich auch zum beispiel
auf eine pizza stein backen oder auf
einem normalen backblech aber ich denke
ihnen auf diesem pizza backblech wird
jetzt einfach ein bisschen knuspriger
deswegen kurz umgesetzt und jetzt streue
ich dann noch ein bisschen thymian
obendrauf
la paz für die optik und für den
geschmack
und so kann jetzt bereits der pizza
kranz bei 200 grad ober und unterhitze
für ungefähr 35 minuten gebacken werden
wohin die zwischenzeit mache ich eine
leckere der pizza ring ist jetzt
gebacken und ich habe ihn jetzt etwa
zehn minuten abkühlen lassen damit
einfach nicht zu halten ist und der
morath sich nicht zu sehr verbrennt und
der ist mir übrigens leider aufgeplatzt
und ich hab mir das wirklich vorher noch
gedacht dass er wahrscheinlich auf
platzen könnte deswegen wäre es ganz gut
wenn ihr ihn vor dem backen hier oben
einfach so an ein paar stellen ein
schneidet er kann es nämlich da oben
raus und platzt eben nicht aus das sieht
aus wie ein riesen schub dollar bestimmt
wahnsinn ich hätte doch kurz vom blech
unter aber nicht schwierig mit dem hals
hängen ganz ganztag hochlager mache ich
das nächste mal schneide ich den mal auf
das riecht einfach unfassbar gewissens
zu bringen lieber als das war jetzt mal
was mich aber geht es zwischen
riesencharakter das riesenkatze das hat
man früher gegeben
also sieht sehr lecker aus und ich finde
es riecht einfach unglaublich gut
du darfst probieren ich probiere das ok
dann probieren hat net auf jeden fall
von der konsistenz her der teig ist er
relativ dünn ausgerollt und außen ist
das schön knusprig innen schön weich und
die aromen die sich dann verbinden also
nicht wirklich unglaublich lecker hier
in der küchenbranche er hat doch
probiert und wirklich genial ohne
wirklich genial
also ich finde auch ich will jetzt auch
gleich ein stück abreißen und ich denke
das ist wirklich so ein cooles party
gericht weil er kann sich dann jeder was
runter schneiden man kann es auch gut
kalt essen weil pizza schmeckt mir
persönlich zum beispiel kalt auch ganz
gut
oder diese pizza muffins diesmal gemacht
habe und variieren könnt ihr das so wie
ihr möchtet als einfach alle zutaten
reihen die er gerne hätte
ob vegetarisch oder mit fleisch ob mit
salami oder mit putenbrust oder mit job
ist egal wo ich muss man
ich finde so gigantisch wahnsinn aber
auch dass noch so schön ja wirklich
klasse auf jeden fall gibt es eine
variante mit einer füllung auf meinem
blog blog de und ich schneide mir jetzt
auch gleich eine scheibe ab und was
sagen ja die meisten leute noch sagen
schuldig er bekommt ja im supermarkt
gibt und dann hat er mich kennt weiß
dass die türkischen supermärkten und ja
da bekommt ihr das auf jeden fall
ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen und wünsche uns beiden einen
guten appetit
bis zum nächsten mal am liebsten
behalten
es packt er noch mal ein